En tout cas, je suis content de t’emmener ici,
tu vas voir il paraît qu’il est excellent ce restau !
Oui je sais je suis déjà venue une fois.
Ah ouais ?
Avec qui ?
Avec Gilles un copain.
D'accord.
Enfin un ex copain.
Oui j'avais compris.
D'ailleurs, tu fais quoi le weekend prochain
je voulais t'emmener à Disney
Ah oui j’adore Disney
avec Pierre c’était trop marrant.
J’ai dis Disney ?
Non mais c'est...j'ai bafouillé,
Je voulais dire le parc Astérix.
Oui le Parc Asterix c’est cool aussi.
Non mais
Tu peux pas m’en vouloir d’avoir vécu avant de te rencontrer.
Non mais je sais.
Et puis les premières fois ça te marque plus c’est comme ça.
Non mais c’est pas...tu m'étonne.
Puis en même temps, moi je m'en fous
j'en ai plein des idées...
Tiens par exemple, t’as déjà fait un bain de minuit ?
Oui
C'est vrais que c'était pas très original ça...
T’as déjà fait l’amour sur la plage ?
Oui
Oui d'accord ok
Bon.
Viens avec moi !
Tu as déjà roulé à 300 km/h ?
Mon ex était pilote.
Fait un saut en parachute ?
Un autre pilote...
T’as déjà infiltré un gang et vendu de la drogue par amour ?
Ouais...Los Chicanos, bro !
Guns in my ass forever.
Tu as déjà nagé avec des dauphins ?
Fait.
Bon heu...un plan à 3 ?
A 4 ?
Fait.
A 17 ?
Los Chicanos,
Guns in my...
Non mais c’est bon j’ai compris !
...forever.
Bon t’as déjà visité Toulon ?
Oui.
Tourcoing ?
Toulouse ?
Oui.
Moscou?
-Oui.
New York?
Dublin?
-Oui.
Rome?
Paris?
-Oui.
Marseille?
Le Havre?
-Oui.
Tourkeunston ?
Oui.
Mais c’est pas possible ! C’est une ville que je viens d’inventer ?
Non mais je rigole parce que je l’avais aussi inventé avec un ex.
Ok et un don d'organe on t'as déjà donné un organe ?
Fait,
il m’a donné un rein.
Ensuite il est mort.
Bon, et des enfants ? C’est bien ça ! Fonder une famille tu l'as pas fait ?
Si, je te présente Isham et Jean Louis,
Dis “bonjour” Jean-Louis
Bonjour !
Bonjour
Bon, et descendre une pente à 30 degrés en long board
en faisant l’amour comme une bête ? Tu l'as pas fait
Justement c’est comme ça que j’ai eu Jean-Louis
C’est pas important
T’as déjà …
Je sais pas …
Fuit ce monde qui nous entoure pour vivre...
une autre réalité ?
Bon t’as déjà vu ton mec
bouffer de la merde,
la vomir
Ensuite rajouter des morceaux de sanglier...
faisandés les morceaux
tu rajoutes des morceaux de lépreux, des trucs dégeulasses
Ensuite tu mixes le tout
tu le ravales
pendant un rite vaudou
où des aiguilles traversent vos deux corps ?
à tout les deux OK ?
Ça tu l'as peut être déjà fait ?
Non ça j’ai jamais fais.
Et du mini golf ?
T’as déjà fait du mini golf ?